[Music]
hello and welcome to this virtual tour
of the rayleigh windmill a tourist and
educational attraction boasting a museum
exhibition space and many interesting
facts and displays showing the history
of rayleigh and the rayleigh mount
the rayleigh windmill also serves as a
popular venue for weddings and other
celebrations
[Music]
the windmill can be found within the
rochford district which is located in
essex the rochford district boasts an
area of 65 square miles and offers
plenty of character and natural beauty
through its wonderful countryside and
miles of coastline
the district is enriched with a
tremendous amount of charm and history
and the windmill perfectly encapsulates
these traits
[Music]
rayleigh itself is an historic market
town and the main center of population
within the districts
the town has retained much of its
traditional character and provides a
vibrant town center
the windmill can be found along
bellingham lane a side road from the
high street
the windmill is a grade two listed
building and this beautiful local
landmark was first built in 1809 it
spent much of the late 20th century
disused but has since been reborn as a
result of extensive restoration work
carried out in 2006 allowing it to
reopen to the public
these restoration works also allowed the
windmill to host celebrations including
weddings with its majestic sales and
picturesque garden it offers a stunning
backdrop for photographs and is perfect
for those looking for a venue full of
charm and romance
[Music]
[Applause]
the windmill is owned and managed by
rochford district council
the red brick tower stands at 55 feet
tall and with the cap and sails included
the windmill stands at 67 feet tall
making it the tallest in essex the sails
on the windmill are around 40 feet in
length and were removed in october 2017
for essential maintenance before being
restored
as you move up each floor reduces in
area as the tower tapers towards the top
of its six floors only the first four
are accessible to the public
adjacent to the windmill is the windmill
garden which provides a lovely and
peaceful area for visitors
[Music]
a commemorative sculpture can be found
within the garden which highlights the
inner workings of the windmill and is
almost seven feet tall weighing
approximately half a ton
the sculpture was designed in
collaboration with local school children
from across the district and was
unveiled in 2009 as part of a
celebration of the 200th anniversary of
the rayleigh windmill
originally when the windmill was
operational each floor had a separate
and important part to play in the flower
producing process
[Music]
the ground floor would mainly be used
for the management of the business and
is where the sacks of grain would have
been received and weighed
additionally administrative tasks
crucial for business would have been
performed here
[Music]
[Laughter]
once received and weighed the sacks of
grain would be winched to the top of the
mill with a hoist and one-way trapdoors
passing through each floor to the top of
the mill
moving up the windmill the first floor
is where the miller worked and
controlled each element of production
all the energy that was created by the
sails would have been brought to this
floor as it would turn the great spur
which was a large wheel that would turn
above the miller's head
this great spur wheel had gears known as
stone nuts which were used to operate
all the various pieces of machinery
present
the next floor is where you would find
three sets of stones which were crucial
for the production of produce at the
windmill utilizing the power coming from
the work of the miller on the floor
below each stone rotated over a static
bed stone
[Music]
the third floor was known as the bin
floor as the grain would have been fed
from the sacks in the floor above into
bins from here the grain would then feed
through into the stones on the second
floor below by passing through the
hopper
continuing upwards the fourth floor was
for the short-term storing of the sacks
of grain whilst they waited to fill the
bins below and then start the whole
process
above this the fifth floor was an area
with a very low ceiling and was known as
the dust floor
the reason for having a dust floor
located here was to minimize the risk of
unwanted debris entering the process by
creating a barrier between the moving
cap and the mill
and finally at the very top of the
windmill we have the cap located on the
sixth floor which also houses the brake
wheel this receives power directly from
the sails and in turn uses the gearing
to send the power to the great spur
wheel with a miller on the second floor
of the windmill
at the rear of the cap is the fan tail
which rotated the cap and sails into the
wind
the windmill cap would be particularly
vulnerable to high wind damage which
would make access for regular
maintenance a very daunting and
dangerous prospect
what a fascinating insight into the
history of the windmill and how this
iconic local building functioned when it
was in operation
now we would love to take a look at what
you can find at the windmill today as
there are many delightful and
interesting things to come along and see
you will be greeted by the wonderful
rayleigh windmill volunteers often in
costume upon your arrival
the volunteers are the foundation upon
which the entire experience is built
their dedication and extensive knowledge
on the history of the windmill is
unparalleled and a highlight for all
visiting
the ground floor is where you can relive
some of the highlights and the history
of the windmill through both the
extensive knowledge of the volunteers
and the storyboards that you can find
displayed across the room
[Music]
you can find further detail on each of
these storyboards by visiting
www.rochford.gov
dot uk forward slash windmill
the ground floor also has a tv screen
for short presentations and offers
footage of the upper floors for those
who are unable to access them
for younger visitors the ground floor
has an activity table with lots of fun
pieces of equipment for them to enjoy
there is a demonstration from the
volunteers on a set of hand-operated
corn stones and how this would have been
used to turn grain into flour when the
windmill was operational
the volunteers also have some
fascinating stories that are always
popular amongst visitors
moving upstairs the first floor is the
windmills museum floor
the items on display are very household
and domestic based with many items being
donated by residents from the local area
the first floor includes many different
exhibits and artifacts offering
delightful insight into some local
history and providing a glimpse into
what life was like for the residents of
raleigh and neighborhoods during the
early years of the 20th century
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
items from both world wars can be found
on display as well as everyday household
items from this time period
[Music]
some of the pieces you will find include
a collection of pre-decimal coins
charity pins including an early poppy
made of silk and a vast array of
historical photos and paper cuttings
showing the life and times of rayleigh
down the years
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
upstairs the second floor of the
windmill now serves mainly as an
exhibition floor for local artists and
community organizations artists are
invited to utilize the space at the
windmill for a few weeks as an
opportunity to showcase their work and
talent to all who visit
during the season we have many different
artists offering a wide variety of art
and technique and the artists remain
present during their exhibition to speak
to visitors to explain their art and
their artistic process also on this
floor thanks to various donations we
have an exhibition displaying a number
of early rural craft items this display
was prompted from the acquisition of a
sac with the logo of the rayleigh
windmill
it was in poor condition as it had been
stored at the back of a barn for many
years but fortunately we were able to
have it restored
[Music]
thelma past field was born at the mill
as her father worked as a wagon driver
for thomas brown the owner of the
windmill at the time
it was a donation from thelma's sister
that paid for the saks restoration and
resulted in the purchase of related
items in order to create a display
reflecting the bygone era of rayleigh's
agricultural and rural past
[Music]
[Music]
finally the third floor is the last that
is still accessible to the public at the
windmill and therefore is the highest we
can go
[Music]
this floor is dedicated to the rayleigh
mount and its history which is in an
area adjacent to the windmill owned by
the national trust the mount was
formerly the location of rayleigh castle
which was a muttoned bailey castle
the castle was built around 1070 and was
referenced in the doomsday book
published in 1086
the castle was built and occupied by
swain who had inherited the land from
his father fitzway mark
the castle was located here at the mount
as it was a natural vantage point for
the entire area this is shown from the
wonderful views you can find from the
third floor of the windmill
these views overlook rayleigh and even
offer sights as far as south end south
wooden ferris and the lachinden water
tower
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a truly iconic local landmark the
rayleigh windmill has been standing tall
and proud for over 200 years
there is so much more to the history of
this wonderful windmill the rayleigh
windmill has been awarded the
accreditation of quality assured visitor
attraction from visit england and is a
national winner of the heritage and
museum awards for customer service we
would love for you to come and visit us
when we are open and meet our lovely
volunteers
further information including details on
the windmills beautiful wedding
ceremonies can be found at
dot www.rochford.gov forward slash
windmill or by calling zero one seven
zero two three one eight one two zero
[Music]
you